We can fit even more complicated
functions to data like this.
I'm going to show you the code of
how to do that in just a moment.
But I wanted to start with
sort of the result, and
then go back into the code and
show you how we did it.
So our original polynomial
is a blue line.
It's under here.
You can't quite see it.
And the noisy data, or
the green dots there.
This purple line is our initial guess.
And the fitted polynomial, the red line
here, fits the original pretty closely.
So let me show you a little more detail.
Here is output from our program.
This is our original polynomial.
It printed in kind of a weird way.
Our original polynomial
is 1.5 x to the fourth,
minus 10 X to the third
minus 5 X squared and so on.
Down here are the results
of our optimization.
So here's what we got instead of 1.5 for
the fourth power,
we got 1.6 Instead of -10 for
the third power we've got -10.5 and
so on.
But overall, pretty close and
as you can see by that chart I just
showed you, you know, very nice fitting.
Let's look now at how
we do that in code.
The code here for,
a higher-degree polynomial is very
similar to what we had for the line.
Again, there's an error function
we're trying to minimize.
And we take in the coefficients for
the polynomial and the actual data.
And our error function is computed here.
Again it's a sum of the difference
between the actual data and
the polynomial value squared.
We take the sum of all those values and
that's our error.
So again very similar to what we did for
the line.
Here's our function that finds
the coefficients of the polynomial
has just a few parameters.
The data the we're trying
to fit our error function.
In other words, how do we measure error
and what are we trying to minimize?
And the degree of the polynomial.
We created an initial guess.
In other words, what do we think
the values of the coefficients are?
And what we're doing here is we're
just setting them all to be ones.
We plot that, and then we call
our minimizer, just like before.
We have to tell it, what's the error
function we're trying to minimize?
What's our initial guess?
We have to pass along the data, which
then gets passed to the error function,
and again, this method, SLS Q P and
finally, you can't see it it is
off to the side there, but same options
essentially they are verbose options.
And that's it that's how we use Python
to create a model based on data.